[Music]
well the question is if we're entering a
new golden age of space exploration what
is the main bottleneck that we face the
main bottleneck has to do with life
support and the human you see we've
already sent robots to Mars we've
already said objects the size of a bus
to the planet Mars
but now we're talking about humans which
require in whole support network and so
we have to realize that things that we
don't even consider at all with robots
become central and a a bottleneck for
humans humans have to live in an
environment where there's radiation
where this loneliness where the journey
could take two years where temperatures
are below freezing where the atmospheric
pressure is only 1% the atmospheric
pressure on the planet Earth and
eventually we want to create a base
there we're not going to go there just a
plant to fly and come back and crow
about it no we want a self-sustaining
plant a base on Mars that could support
people this means it has to be done in
several steps the first step would be to
create a base on Mars with power solar
power could provide the energy and lava
tubes underground lava tubes might be
able to provide caves by which
astronauts could live and create the
first outpost underground that's the way
it was done in the movie 2001 the moon
base on the moon in that movie was
underground providing a natural barrier
to radiation and then once you have the
base set up you have to begin the
process of creating a self-sustaining
agriculture there I mean what are you
gonna eat on Mars you can't order a
hamburger because everything has to be
shipped from the planet Earth you want
to create an agriculture and this means
genetic engineering this means creating
genetically modified algae and plants
that can consume the rich carbon dioxide
atmosphere live in a very cold
environment and thrive then we have to
create mining operations we have to
the ice ice can provide oxygen for
breathing water for drinking and
hydrogen for rocket fuel and so we have
to begin a mining operation so that we
have the materials to build cities
materials to build bases oxygen to
breathe water to drink and hydrogen for
a rocket fuel then the last step in the
process and this will take maybe another
hundred years is to send satellites
satellites orbiting around Mars to begin
the process of melting the polar ice
caps this is called space solar power we
have the blueprints already the problem
is cost but the costs are dropping for
sending payloads into outer space
dramatically and so people are once
again dusting off these old plans to
create satellites around the earth
satellites around Mars that can beam
energy and begin the process of melting
the ice caps now once you raise the
temperature of Mars by about six degrees
once the temperature of Mars rises six
degrees it becomes autocatalytic
it takes off it becomes self-feeding
because the more heat you have on Mars
the more carbon dioxide you loft into
the atmosphere which creates more
greenhouse effect which allows you to
melt even more ice to raise a
temperature even more so you have a
positive feedback loop the question is
can we reach six degrees that's the key
point if we can raise the surface
temperature of Mars by six degrees we
can create this artificial spiral by
which it feeds on itself and we can
begin the process of terraforming Mars
and so remember robots don't need
terraforming humans do and so to make
more suitable for humans that's going to
be the big problem
[Music]